[applause]
You actually saw it. That is, it
turns out
that there is a riser on the left, that is, there was a chance that what
is below is like a layer
cake, I think there are no chances anymore,
and We tried to break through from below through the
basements, the basement is also destroyed, that is, the
rocket finished off, it turns out already  to the very
bottom, that is, we can’t even
drill from the basements, as it were, from below.
Well, heavy, that is, we have somewhere around
70 people asked for help, of which
somewhere up to 10 are already heavy, all
heavy, that is, people crushed by
slabs And most importantly That  there is a
temperature of -3,
complete hypothermia and carbon monoxide poisoning,
but this is one hundred percent Van Handel, this is
preset, this is
Russian missile strikes x22, that is, well, I
personally was and there were military ones, that is, they
even found a hatch from it